living on the sidewalk in shelters built
of scrap metal and plastic sheeting this
group of homeless people in cape town
have been here for two years now in 2019
they occupied a vacant old people's home
on the site days later city authorities
evicted them and demolished the building
we are in the suburbs now together with
everybody that is in town so now
when they are kicking us again out they
are showing that they want to keep this
city right
they don't want anybody here except
white people
is in this city
while the eviction has been taken to
court the lives of people here remain in
limbo this land's been sold to a
developer and barbara is hoping the
courts will intervene
there is definitely a prioritization of
capital in our city
the needs of the poor are not being met
if they are if housing developments are
created it is usually created on
far-flung areas on the outskirts of our
city
which just in effect replicates the
special apart that that has plagued the
city of cape town since colonialism
but the city says it's working to
integrate different communities within
the inner city and that it's developing
10 sites for affordable housing and that
over 10 years it's built close to 70 000
low-cost units
but there's a backlog of 300 000 people
waiting for a home and the city says it
has to prioritize those at the top of
the waiting list any project that we do
has qualifying beneficiaries now let me
make an example if tomorrow you you knew
very well that in this particular
development next to parliament you are
going to benefit from now there's
someone who's being evicted elsewhere
and then that person will remove you
from that particular list we put someone
else is that fair it can be fair because
we have to accommodate some a person who
has who has qualified and who's been
waiting
but here in the suburb of woodstock
families say they've been on the waiting
list for housing for more than a decade
one of them is charnel commando and a
family who are now being evicted from a
home they've lived in for generations
this community has also taken city
authorities to court to avoid being
moved to outlying areas
city officials have had to relocate
thousands of people evicted from prime
land within the city while some say
they're willing to move many others
complain it's often to the outskirts of
cape town to areas like this one where
there are fewer facilities and it's
further away from the city where there
are work opportunities
people at this resettlement camp say
where they live is pushing them further
into poverty
in a city already plagued by deep
economic disparities
family al jazeera cape town